hey guys welcome back to another mkbhd
video as you might have noticed on the
top of my channel here there is a new
section besides all these called the
mobile options section and if i expand
it you're going to notice this is a
brand new section that youtube partners
have that includes a mobile channel
banner so you can now have graphics on
your
m.youtube.com version of your site so if
you have a channel that has a banner on
your desktop version why not have it on
the mobile version so today i'm going to
be showing you guys how to make a banner
for the mobile version of your youtube
channel now there really aren't too many
restrictions with this mobile channel
banner all you need to know is that
there are two of them there is a
portrait version for when their device
is in portrait mode and that has its own
resolution and a landscape version for
when they rotate their device there's a
little more room so there's a slightly
bigger landscape channel banner i'm
going to go ahead and make the portrait
version of the banner in this tutorial
and you can go ahead and do whatever you
want for the landscape version but it
can be pretty similar if you'd like
for this project for the portrait
channel banner i'm using [ __ ] which is
the gnu image manipulation program it's
free and multi-platform but if you have
photoshop that will do as well now
taking a look at what the youtube site
says the portrait version is 320 by 50
pixels so what we're going to do is make
a new document here and this is just
going to be freeform uh 320 by 50 pixels
not a whole lot of editing going on here
in terms of video editing but i'm going
to be showing you a making of a very
simple banner now as you can tell when
this is on the mobile site it's going to
be really really small so there's not a
whole lot of
things you can do with this small amount
of space so one of the things i suggest
is just having a simple gradient and a
text box and an image of some sort so
when i say simple gradient i mean like a
background of two different colors maybe
your channel has a sort of a red and
black theme so you can choose a red to
black gradient or a red to a darker red
gradient something like that and you can
make a gradient just like that um an
ingredient really is something that can
make it just a little bit more visually
appealing in terms of where it shows up
on the mobile site it really catches the
eye so now that you have a bright red
background on the white youtube mobile
site you can really add some contrast by
putting some text in there so i'm going
to add text on the left hand side and go
ahead and line it up with all the rest
and put it on the left hand side i'm
going to say
for example mkbhd now you could put
subscribe in that box you could put
you know click here to view more videos
in that box you can put whatever you
want there but make sure it has some
sort of contrast with the rest of your
image so i have this black and i'm going
to change use the font that i've used in
a lot of my videos a lot of you guys
were asking what font that was and that
is babas new and it's available at
dafont.com
so if you guys are familiar with
installing free fonts on your computer
you can definitely do that so that'll be
centered on that side of the banner see
it's a nice simple text box you know has
quite a bit of contrast
with the red background
now that alone on the youtube site still
will be pretty readable see as small as
i make it it's still pretty visible
and one more thing that i'm going to add
is another image that i have my
watermark is a png image and it is just
the bottom right hand corner and i can
go ahead and i open that up in [ __ ] and
i'll put it on the right hand side
corner here so i'll go ahead and open
that in a new [ __ ] window
sorry about the graphics so
this is the image that i want to take i
can go ahead and edit copy
and
paste this image to be on the right hand
side
and here you can see it's a little too
big for the banner i currently have
going on
so what i will do is scale it down now
remember we said this whole thing this
banner right here was 50 pixels tall so
we're going to go ahead and make this a
50 by 50 image scale it down
and bring this back into view
so now on this top of this background we
have a a floating image that we can put
wherever we want uh and hopefully it
will be you know wherever we want it to
be and still when you zoom out on the
youtube mobile site wherever you put
this it's going to be pretty visible uh
you can decide you know what image you
want to put there things like that i'm
not actually going to add this i'll
delete this now but you get the point
you can add whatever you want to this
small little strip banner here now when
you're done you need to make sure you
save it to the appropriate file type so
you can go to file save as
and make sure you save this as a png or
jpg image so i'll save this as mobile
banner.png
and put this on my desktop for good luck
and hit save and [ __ ] or photoshop
whatever you're using will ask you to
export it and we'll go ahead and save
everything there now we can close [ __ ]
here is the mobile banner on our desktop
so now what we want to do is go ahead
and implement this on our youtube
channel so we're going to go back to
youtube.com and go ahead and upload this
banner i'm not going to upload this
particular banner because i have a
different one that i've uploaded but
i'll show you what you need to do to
upload it it's really quite simple you
go back to your channel of course and
you'll go back to that mobile options
button click it
and go down here to the portrait channel
banner which is what we just designed up
here in the corner we can delete this
one and there will be a select file
button and you can go ahead and upload
that selected file also make sure you
have the banner button over here checked
to the left and you can add any url you
want say you want to add your website
when someone taps on your banner on
their ipad or iphone or android device
or something like that you can go ahead
and add your website or an external link
or whatever you want to be there once
you're done with all this customization
you can select your colors which are
probably going to be the same as what
you leave on your typical channel on the
desktop version and hit save changes and
just like that you will have a banner on
the mobile version of your site so now
let's go ahead and check out see what it
looks like
alright guys so on my droid we're going
to take a look at the final versions of
the banners that i made for the mkbhd
youtube channel i made a little bit of
changes i actually use a white to gray
gradient and use my logo in the right
hand corner and some different text but
overall if you guys want to check it out
on your own mobile device you can follow
these steps to find it and view the
final versions of these banners yourself
right now i'm searching for marquez
brownlee in mobile youtube and i can
just click on the first video and
underneath the link on that first video
is a link to my channel so we'll click
my name
and take a look at those banners this
portrait version of the banner just has
my logo in the bottom right hand corner
and says one word subscribe it's very
big text so it's very visible even on
smaller screens rotating it to landscape
changes the one word subscribe into two
words subscribe today so as you can see
i took pretty good advantage of the
increased estate that i got with turning
it widescreen and i added two words
instead of one and back in portrait it's
just one word subscribe so i think
that's a pretty good use of the banner
making it just a little bit different
but still very consistent in the theme
so that's about it for this tutorial i
know it was an absurdly long video i
normally don't make videos seven and a
half minutes long but i'm sure this will
be helpful for a lot of people who are
looking to get their channel off the
ground and have a mobile banner to go
with it all so in the end mkbhd signing
out see you in the next video peace
you